you might wonder why i'm beginning this
unboxing video showing you our
17 year old almost 18 year old cat
sassy well the answer to that lies
in that box that's right over next to
her
which hopefully contains something
that will help her out so
i'm going to show you that in just a
minute
but this is her special bed with
my packers shirt and her blanket
she's uh she's quite a cat
so hopefully what we've got coming up
will be
something of interest to her
so this arrived yesterday and hopefully
it is what we're anticipating
it being which is
something special that my wife
researched
and we thought we could actually use
for sassy one of the things that i used
to do
all the time was take a mica or dog out
for walks
and so here we go
uh we have two things
that came with this we have a harness
so let's see what we got here
harness system it looks like i don't
know if sassy's gonna be
entirely cool with that but we'll we'll
see we'll put it on there and see
how it works looks nice and form fitting
this looks like a tiny little
leash to go with it and then the big
thing
is this other
contraption that is coming with it
there we go all this packaging that they
have
so it's you know you look at it and it's
like a little bag
that a cat goes into
and i should be able to carry
her around with me and take her on some
trips some little walks here and there
so we'll see how well this actually
works and if she's amenable to it or not
so let's see what she thinks of this
she's definitely interested in sniffing
it
and it might be something interesting
for her we'll see if she gets
enthusiastic about this or
maybe the opposite where she's totally
unenthused about it so clearly it goes
over and under at the same time
let's see whether she's amenable
to getting into it might be a little bit
too tight like that let's loosen it up a
bit
there we go oh she's purring
she's kind of into it here we go little
girl
there we go yeah let's try this out
what do you think what do you think
about this
you know she's not used to having
anything on her like this so i don't
know
how much she's gonna like it but
there we go that looks like how it's
supposed to go
on her i'm assuming and then you could
like
put the leash on but maybe we'll
we'll leave that alone for for the
moment
there we go what do you think little
baby girl
what do you think is that all right
we'll see how she how she does with it
turns out i had it on her backwards
now you can see her moving along
prowling around
she's actually doing pretty well with it
given that
she's not used to wearing anything like
that she's
playing with a raw catnip that i
brought in from outside for her
so and she seems to be doing okay
so this is the other component it's a
pouch that i can carry her around in
and hopefully it's big enough we'll see
how she does i'm going to try putting
her into it
and we'll see how that goes
i mean you all right here we go
sassy has taken trips with me before
like in my
sweatshirt or hoodie or jacket
but this is the first time that she's
ever had something
specifically just for her set up like
this so
it may be she may not be a big
fan we'll see how how it works
there we go sorry baby girl
here we go i'm gonna take a little walk
huh
take a little trip i think i gotta move
her back legs a bit
so that she's not curled up quite the
way that she is
let's give this another shot here we go
squeaker
yeah we're gonna do a little
special sassy trip
all right let's see if we can make this
work this time
oh there we go zipping her up
there we go there we go
all right there what do you think of
that
what do you think of that should we
tighten that up a little bit so it's
like a little
blankie around you
so we're gonna give this a shot she's
reasonably secure she isn't yowling so
that's actually a pretty good sign
we can move it around quite a bit so
she can be with me and we can go and now
we can
take walks around outside
explore this is something we've been
wanting to do for a long time
especially since you know the dogs are
gone
and uh sassy's you know
just me and and my wife and sassy here
in the apartment so
this way she can actually get a bit more
stimulation
see some other people see some other
animals although i don't know that she's
actually gonna
like the other animals we'll see how it
works
i can't tell from her face whether she's
really enjoying this or not but she's
looking around
so i think we'll go try this out
in just a bit and see how it works out
for her and for us
you